Hello everyone.
Thank you for tuning into laying focus
TV.
I am your host Paul and today we're
going to talk about the difference
between informal and formal language and
which one you should focus on learning
when you're learning a new language.
We have two special guests with us
today.
They both happened to be cousins of
mine.
One is my cousin Fred and the other is
my cousin Ivan.
So welcome to both of you.
Yo,
what's up?
Okay,
so let's start off by talking about some
of the differences between formal
language and informal language and later
on we'll get into which one you should
focus on learning when you learn a new
language.
So far more frank,
I'd like to start with you.
Would you tell us a little bit about
formal language and how it differs from
informal language?
Formal speech usually mirrors the
written language,
so when people are speaking formally,
they are speaking with the written
language in mind.
They might be seeing the sentences
inside their head as they are saying
them.
They are keeping grammar and mind.
They're conscious of grammar and they're
constructing those sentences carefully
to follow the rules of grammar that they
learned in school.
And they might be using some vocabulary
that they see written in books,
but they don't usually use in casual
conversation.
And maybe the most important thing,
the most important differences that they
are enunciating all of the words very
clearly.
So the people who find the formal
language quite easy to learn are people
who are visual learners and people who
are kind of analytical.
So that gets them thinking about the
different pieces of the sentence and how
to put them together.
Those kinds of people learn the formal
language quite easily,
and they're typically tend to be quite
introverted.
So I'm this type of person,
I'm this type of learner.
I find it quite easy to learn the formal
language,
well,
relatively easy to learn the formal
language.
I find it easier to learn how to
understand news broadcasts in a new
language than I do to understand casual
conversations on the street.
That's the type of learner I am
naturally,
just because of my personality and my
learning style.
I'm a visual learner.
I'm introverted and I'm quite
analytical.
Hmm.
That's all very interesting.
So let's hear from informal.
Ivan,
can you tell us a little bit about
informal language and how that's
different from the formal language that
frank described and the people who
learned a formal language really easily.